as popular and beloved as the Star Wars
movies are there are several actors who
had bad experiences working on them and
that includes some of the biggest names
in the series I thought I'd take a look
at the reasons why
okay good news bad news starting out the
good news is that Mark Hamill The Man
Behind Luke Skywalker himself was
generally happy about the role Mark
became a mega star after the first movie
came out and had nothing but amazing
things to say about his experience for
years it's funny isn't it the bad news
that streak ended after filming the
eighth movie Star Wars The Last Jedi
Mark said he didn't dig the direction
his character was headed a path set by
director Ryan Johnson he even said that
he started thinking of the Skywalker in
that particular movie as a totally
different one than the guy he played he
said and I quote maybe he's Jake
Skywalker who is this guy which is so
weird because that's the name I use for
my Starbucks orders either way it was
soups awkward because if anyone is going
to be a fierce defender of all things
Star Wars you figure it'll be luke right
Mark eventually came to his senses and
posted an apology on Twitter he even
made a point of saying that once he saw
the whole movie put together he realized
he was wrong so it sounds like he had a
visit from Obi-Wan to set him straight
and by Obi-Wan I actually mean several
top Disney Executives same same speaking
of Mr Kenobi sir Alec Guinness was
another actor who had issues with the
franchise now In fairness when the first
movie was being made nobody really knew
how much of a big deal it would be so
you have this total Pro of the acting
world who had won awards and made a ton
of Bank on stage and on screen cut to
him reading a script with a dude in a
black suit and breathing machine chasing
after a couple other dudes and a furry
creature yeah the whole thing probably
seemed a little dubious in fact we know
he thought that because he wrote some
letters to a buddy during production
calling the movie quote fairy tale
rubbish and the dialogue pretty ropey
dang Alex tell us what you really think
and yet he trudged on why well he had a
crush on the head of the Wardrobe
Department I'm kidding it was his
paycheck he made 150 000 for the part
way more than everyone else but more
importantly he got two percent of
whatever George Lucas made from the box
office Moolah so he ended up pulling in
about a hundred million dollars money
that still comes to his estate even
after his death and honestly you'd look
like a hundred million bucks if you hit
that subscribe button just saying
speaking of the costume Department
another major star of the Star Wars
Universe at one point made the statement
I was glad to see that costume for the
last time that grumpy comment was made
by Mr Grumpy pants himself Han Solo or
actually the guy who played Han Harrison
Ford apparently Harrison has had a
love-hate relationship with the
franchise for a while now I mean it's
probably hard to fully hate the thing
that turned you into a huge movie star
right and yet Harrison clearly had his
issues with the movies and the scripts
apparently he said to writer George
Lucas you can type this George but you
sure as hell can't say it referring to a
clunky bit of dialogue now In fairness
it's possible it was all said and jest
and he was just having a little fun with
the legendary Star Wars creator after
all there's definitely evidence of
Harrison and having fun on set but what
we do know is that at the very least
Harrison got tired of playing Han Solo
after a while he was apparently pretty
hesitant to even sign on to the second
and third movies but he eventually did
and in what has to be a first in
Hollywood he actually pitched the idea
that Han should get killed and Empire
Strikes Back what an actor looking for
Less screen time bunkers and before he
did make a comeback in the force awakens
Ford said for years he wasn't interested
in making a return to the character this
went as far back as an interview in 1983
on The Today Show where he said that
quote about not wanting to ever be in
that costume again I guess ultimately he
got his wish when eight-year-old spoiler
alert Han got killed in the force
awakens it's not a spoiler alert to say
that John boyega was one of the breakout
stars of the latest series of Star Wars
movies his character Finn was introduced
in the force awakens and spent the next
three movies battling the forces of
supreme leader snoke kylo Ren and the
emperor but apparently Jon felt like he
was really battling another evil force
racism in an interview after episode 9
came out the rise of Skywalker boyega
put the writers and directors on blast
for poor treatment of his character and
other characters played by people of
color he noted that it was poor form for
Disney to introduce a black character
promising that they're going to be
involved in a major way in the plot and
then sort of keep them as a supplemental
character but that's exactly what they
did in John's opinion he talked about
how they gave certain characters aka the
white ones nuance and agency this meant
Adam Driver and Daisy Ridley's
characters among others but that they
sort of pushed Finn's character to the
side as the movies went on it left a
super bad taste in Jon's mouth and while
he has called The Experience an amazing
opportunity clearly he's glad to be done
with it now C-3PO and R2D2 were
definitely supplemental characters and
were always meant to be but that doesn't
mean they weren't fan favorites sadly it
appears Anthony Daniels and Kenny Baker
the actors inside those robot suits
weren't favorites of each other in
fairness according to Baker who played
Artu it was more that Daniels was kind
of a jerk to him and others on set it
was hard enough for them to really
communicate with each other inside those
giant costumes I mean you spend all day
in the giant metal suit and see how
chipper you are but regardless Daniels
apparently would address Baker as little
man and generally acted like he was
better than Baker Baker also revealed
that he eventually found out it wasn't
just him Daniels didn't get along with
most of the people on set in addition to
his feuding with Baker and others
Daniels also got pissed when they had
him only voice 3PO in later movies after
being inside the suit for the original
ones he even referred to the CGI version
of him as terrible okay I'm gonna go try
to soothe my inner child that is
suddenly super disappointed at the
people who made Star Wars I just hope
the actor is making Andorra and the
Mandalorian are happy because otherwise
I'm gonna probably lose it if you know
of anyone else who was unhappy making
Star Wars pop it in the comment section
[Music]